and the psychoanalysts i think it air
too much on the side of the subject they
tend to think the too much of you is
inside of you and too little of you is
outside of you and part of the reason I
believe that is because of my clinical
experience I love the psychoanalyst man
they're brilliant they're brilliant
they're deep they grapple with real
problems like with the problems when
people have real problems and I mean
profound problems they're really
profound moral problems or problems of
good and evil really you know there are
things going on in their family that are
so terrible that well that there there
are sometimes fatal
you know lie upon lie upon lie upon lie
for decades and decades and decades
awful and that's not exactly inside them
it's out there in the world and lots of
the people that I see very famous critic
of psychology I can't remember his name
but I probably will criticize the
practice of psychology quite effectively
in the leave in the early 60s the myth
of mental illness by Thomas says s dead
AF dead to classic you should read it if
you're interested in psychology read it
like it's a classic and he basically
said most people have problems in living
they don't have psychological problems
and so I've experienced despite my love
for the psychoanalyst very frequently
what I'm doing as a therapist is helping
people have a life that would work you
know and you can parameterize that like
what do you need how about some friends
that people kind of like that how about
an intimate relationship with someone
that you can trust that maybe has a
future that would be good
how about a career that puts you in a
dominant are key somewhere so at least
you've got some possibility of rising
some possibility of stabilizing yourself
and their schedule in a routine
because no one can live without a
routine you just forget that if you guys
don't have a routine I would recommend
like you get one going because you
cannot be mentally healthy without a
routine you need to pick a time to get
up whatever time you want but pick one
and stick to it because otherwise you
dis regulate your circadian rhythms and
they regulate your mood and eat
something in the morning I had lots of
clients who had anxiety disorders I had
one client who was literally starving
very smart girl
cheaters very little that she liked she
kind of tried to subsist on like half a
cup of rice a day she came to me and
said I have no energy I come home all I
want to do is watch the same movie over
and over what like is that weird and I
thought well it depends how hard you
work you know it's little weird but
whatever familiar you're looking for
comfort so I did an analysis of her diet
it's like three quarters of a cup of
rice it's like you're starving eat
something you know
you'll feel better so she modified her
diet and you're all her anxiety went
away and she had some energy like yeah
you go out to eat
so schedule now that's a good thing man
your brain will thank you for it it will
stabilize your nervous system with a bit
of a plan that's a good thing you need a
career you need something productive to
do with your time you need to regulate
your use of drugs and alcohol most
particularly alcohol because that does
even a lot of people you need a family
like the family you have your parents
and all that be nice if you all go along
you could work on that that's a good
thing to work on it then you know you
probably need children at some point
that's life that's what life is and if
you're missing you know you may have a
good reason to not be operating on one
of those dimensions it's not mandatory
but I can tell you that if you're not
operating reasonably well on for I think
I mentioned six if you're not operating
reasonably well on at least three of
there's no way you're going to be
psychologically thriving and that's more
pragmatic in some sense than
psychological right human beings have a
nature there's things we need and if we
have them well that's good and if we
don't have them well then we feel the
lack and so behaviorist behavioral
psychologist concentrates a lot more on
that sort of thing
you know it's practical it's like
strategizing make a career plan figure
out how to negotiate because that's
bloody important figure out how to say
what you need figure out how to tell the
truth to people figure out how to listen
to your partner in particular because if
you listen to them they will actually
tell you what they want and sometimes
you can give it to them and maybe
they'll return the favor and if you
practice that for like 15 years well
then maybe you're constantly giving each
other what you want well hooray
that would be good and then there's two
of you under wolf circumstances and it's
better to have two brains than one
because people think differently because
of their temperament mostly and so the
negotiation is where the wisdom arises
and it's part of the transformation the
psychological transformation that's
attendant on an intimate relationship
and one of the fundamental purposes of a
long-term intimate relationship